from our first second lesson maybe
though one of the themes are what we're
doing today or in this course rather is
to think deeply about simple things now
symmetry is a simple thing symmetry is a
simple thing I know and I very much
enjoyed by the way reading your um your
posts from last Friday I didn't I didn't
mention that people are talking about
all of the interesting things which oh
my god it's so simple and so obvious but
we've never thought about it before okay
now under the symmetry today you'd have
to write this but the idea is that
symmetry is more than you think
number one or most importantly really
there are more symmetries than you think
okay so let's start off like this and
underneath here and let's make a little
dull boy the first kind of symmetry
let's talk about three distinct types of
surgery and then deep down a little
further okay the first kind of symmetry
is the one you're familiar with and we
actually um we refer to it's very very
briefly at the end of yesterday's lesson
on the four color theorem we talked
about reflecting and rotating and
translating right now all three of those
all three of those okay a symmetries of
geometry we call them geometric
symmetries
now you know three of them I'm going to
introduce you to another two today
there's tons more but before we dig in
deeper in there I want to show you
there's even more symmetries than that
I'll give you an example and I'll
illustrate it for you one of the most
important ones is physical symmetries
this isn't where there are shapes but
where there are other things that are
well can we substitute a water for
symmetry what might be a good synonym
that we could use instead of symmetry
hmm equal good I'm in the top right when
there's things of equality right on any
other words you could suggest to me mmm
same yeah same equivalent a word that I
think is really helpful which is similar
to all of these but it's it's so visual
is on his balance balance so these are
symmetrical that they are balanced
there's a there's a sort of equality or
sameness to them right okay so let me
illustrate a physical one to you now
some of you are some of you may know
what I'm about to illustrate which is
fine but don't spoil it for the rest of
us okay now if you don't know then you
can you can play along now I have two
things here for you okay I've got a
sheet of paper and then I have a ream of
paper they don't know how many sheets of
paper and a ream 500 exactly right okay
so this sheet of paper and this rain
this ream is 500 times after a little
more than five money because it's
wrapping 500 times heavier and my piece
of paper okay now I have a question for
you okay I'm gonna have to scrunch this
up have I changed the mass of this piece
of paper at all I haven't write the same
mass because we're the same planets the
same weight as well okay it's just in a
different shape you contend with that
okay now what I'm going to do in a
second I'm gonna get up higher to do
this to actually do it so that you can
see a little better but I'm gonna drop
these in a second we're gonna drop them
on the table be a bit of a bang okay now
some of you don't know what I'm about to
do so like I said don't spoil it your
run now here's what I'm going to do
don't don't say this out loud I just
want you to try it up think in your mind
what you think the answer will be when I
drop these okay piece of paper ream of
paper and they're going to both hit the
table which one do you think will hit
the table first okay
now I'm sure some of you have seen this
before okay
in fact under like you ten motion okay
you probably would have done something
like this right so I wonder what you
think which one will get do you think of
a piece of paper well here the first it
is it is smaller go faster do you think
the ream of paper will go down first
it's it's heavy up right okay I'm gonna
do it right you ready
so because it's a really heavy and it's
quite heavy this will make a bit of bang
that's why I had to move them like okay
so let's try
this need a bit of space now you're
gonna have to watch very carefully and I
advise the people to bank actually mail
understand so you can see this nice and
clearly okay yeah let's see other the
drop it from this high okay can you see
it can everyone see the two objects okay
and I'll repeat it if your bike if you
don't mind the baby what you want very
carefully which one you think will land
first okay you ready I'll catch you
three two one
huh hold on a second is my question for
you uh why why
okay all right so you're suggesting
everything falls at the same way but I I
challenge that why should they
because clearly like okay you can uh you
can hold this right like for example you
can hold this and you can hold this okay
no we can pass this around if you like
right clearly the paper right the piece
of paper is like in your hand it's
hardly falling at all in your hand oh
you don't think so it's that much force
against it right whereas the ring of
papers cut this it's literally dragging
down on it as you can tell don't have
huge muscles right so it's it's coming
why is that by the way what okay all
right all right so let's split up so
I've got here's Mike he's my um he's my
crumpled up sheet of paper okay and he's
my own
he's my ream of paper okay and you can
see I've drawn them so perfectly that
they're exactly the same distance from
the earth okay right now you're saying
to me you're saying to me this that this
is happening right the earth is pulling
these two things down right but the same
time right both of these objects are
actually pulling on me up like this
right okay now I like this I like this
explanation the first thing is that you
can see there is symmetry here there is
balance right which is why they hit
exactly the same time right there's
another way you can explain it which i
think is probably the same kind of
explanation it just doesn't talk about
means if if let's put I suppose needs to
be oh man I want you to picture a car
okay there's my car right now when you I
don't know if you've ever seen a car
broken down in the street right and like
there are people trying to push it okay
people trying to push it along there you
go he's a guy he's trying to push it
okay what was certainly right definitely
if it was me it was only one guy right
they're not gonna be able to push that
car why not why not
it's
obvious reason why not it's heavy
it's an it's hard to push right it's
staying still and it's hard to get it to
not stay still it's hard to move it
right now we have a name for this right
starts with an i what's that called it's
called inertia right inertia wants it to
keep doing whatever it's doing which in
this case is stay put
okay now many of the arena paper flaps
for singing and that's good so there is
inertia right for both of these and this
ream of paper with more mass has more
inertia this piece of paper right so if
you want to think about this way okay
both of these being pulled to the earth
right you know what this um this
diagrams are misleading this force
actually is green earth it actually is
greater so why do these end up the same
well it's pulling harder right on this
heavy object but not only is a point
hard up it has to pull harder to get it
to move right just like the car okay the
cars heavy the ream of paper is heavy
right what's my point again there's this
strange signature you can't describe
this in like geometric terms really but
you talked about yesterday
all right one more then you're like
really is this mass yes this really
these mats
I'll make sure I spell this right all
right yeah I think so there are logical
symmetries when you see the Elmwood knew
the prefix nearer what does that mean
that means brain goods so there's like
neuroscience and that kind of thing okay
I'm gonna tell you about two kinds of
neurological symmetry okay the first one
the first one comes from a I'm a paper
that was published in 1992 the
scientific paper I'll write out the name
for you to look it up later on okay it
was cold understanding but it's a new
row
okay not tonight - it's an old study
okay understanding motor events they
don't mean like boom-boom boner right
like this they just mean wake up their
tour email it's a great answer
it's just that motion that's all it
means motion we're not the same ideas so
it's about people moving things okay
now what these are what these
researchers did in 1992 was there
watching monkeys and watching monkeys
okay and they were trying to understand
what's happening in the brain as motor
events as as they move things like move
their fingers and their their arms and
so on okay they had those scanners
hooked up to them all these electrodes
and so on and they were measuring all of
the brain electrical activity okay now
what was really interesting was they
could notice predictably the patterns
that happen when you know Mikey would
pick something up or manipulated in
their hands or things like that
okay but the really cool thing that
happened was there's my own there's my
person let me put a monkey next to him I
can yell when the monkeys were not doing
anything but when they watched another
person like a human being doing those
things like picking something up or
manipulating with their hands those
kinds of things okay sitting there still
nothing in their hands exactly the same
kind of stuff was happening in their
brains as it did when they were actually
moving things can I say that again they
weren't doing anything they were just
watching someone do those same actions
but their brain was rehearsing it okay
now back in 1902 it's really funny they
published this paper and people were
kind of like you may be boring no big
deal no one kicked up a fuss about it
and then they realize they caught up to
something huge oh so she's they gave it
a name it called mirror neurons anyone
heard of them
now you can even see in the name right
they are appealing to geometric sort of
language here right but they're parts of
the brain that they are designed to and
this is how we learn we imitate you
watch something else someone else do
something yeah okay my brain is kind of
rehearsing it along with you okay so
there's the first kind of brain science
type symmetry the other one which refers
to you know beauty symmetry or a mental
method is a totally different thing
which is what we call empathy what is
empathy it's a definition for empathy
yes don't like you support right how
would you define it yeah good yeah it's
it's when you share someone's emotions
right it's now one of the phrases the
synonyms for this is putting yourself in
someone else's shoes okay there are
symmetries here which we deeply
recognize a really important okay